Speaker 1: Well the Republican who invented
his entire back story, including his religion,
education and work history, is now admitting
that he did it.
But he says, listen, none of it was a crime.
I didn't commit any crime.
And I plan to be a member of the U.S. House
of Representatives.
We're talking, of course, about George Santos.
The New York Post scored an interview with
Santos and they call it liar.
Representative elect George Santos admits
fabricating key details of his bio.
I am not a criminal, he said.
This controversy will not deter me from having
good legislative success.
I will be effective.
I will be good, he says.
My sins here are embellishing my resumé.
I'm sorry, he confessed.
He never worked directly for Goldman Sachs
and Citigroup, which he claimed to have done,
saying it was a poor choice of words that
he worked for Link Bridge, which did business
with those companies.
All right.
A little bit different.
He says he stated it poorly.
He admitted he never actually graduated from
any college, even though he said I graduated
from Baruch College in 2010.
I didn't graduate from any institution of
higher learning.
I'm embarrassed and sorry for having embellished
my resume.
I own up to that.
We do stupid things in life.
It's not really embellishing to say I graduated
from a college I didn't graduate from.
It's a lie.
Now, on the issue of being Jewish sent the
article says Santos was also accused of lying
about his family history, saying on his campaign
website his mother was Jewish and his grandparents
escaped the Nazis during World War Two.
Remember, no evidence exists to back that
up.
Santos now says he's, quote, clearly Catholic
but claimed his grandmother told stories about
being Jewish and later converting to Catholicism.
Santos said, I never claim to be Jewish.
I said I was Jew hyphen ish.
Oh, boy.
He argues, technically, none of this is a
crime.
That's what he's going with.
Speaker 2: I'm not a criminal.
Not here, not abroad.
In any jurisdiction in the world.
Have I ever committed any crimes?
Right down to the nitty gritty.
I'm not a.
Speaker 1: Fraud.
I like that.
The nit and gritty.
Not the nitty gritty.
To get down to the nit and the gritty, beautiful.
Speaker 2: Not a criminal who defrauded the
entire country and made up institutional character.
Speaker 1: And ran it is fictitious and fictitious.
And it is a fiction.
The knit and gritty of the fictional character
is really coming to light.
Speaker 2: Congress I've been around a long
time.
I mean, a lot of people know me.
They know who I am, their business dealings
with me.
I'm not going to make excuses for this.
But he.
Speaker 1: Kind of is.
Speaker 2: Like a lot of people overstate
in their resumes or twist a little bit or
in grandeur themselves.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God, in grandeur.
Dear God, if he said Ingratiate, it would
not make sense.
But in grand it's all this guy doesn't know
what's going on.
Now I'm actually learning much more about
this.
So psychological explanations for this, not
from me, but from mental health experts about
why people do this.
Why do people do this?
One possibility, they just have a tendency
towards pathological lying.
It's almost like a reflex.
They have a it's a compulsion.
It's a compulsion to just lie often for no
apparent reason.
I've told the story of someone I knew when
I was in high school and they said, My, my
glasses are $500.
This was a very long time ago.
Nobody had $500, just prescription glasses.
My glasses were $500 because they're special.
I don't even care about your glasses.
Why are you lying about that?
It doesn't make any sense.
I don't care one way or the other.
All right?
It's a compulsion.
They can't control it.
And often it comes with a lack of remorse
or a lack of a feeling of guilt when you do
it, which is sort of what we're seeing here.
Another possibility is that it's a need for
attention and validation.
And so it's not a compulsion to lie.
It's this desire to be validated by people,
to be seen as good, to be seen as smart and
all these different things.
And it can also be just as simple as it was
calculated, because he thought it would help
him when he he realized his actual record
wasn't very good.
And so he made it up because he thought it
would help him win, which, by the way, it
appears to have helped.
He should resign.
He's not going to.
Here's a really funny clip, by the way, where
Kevin McCarthy touts we have so many Jewish
people joining us and he mentions George Santos.
It's great, but I really.
Speaker 3: Want to talk about who's the makeup
of this new majority you heard from some of
all already.
You know, Max Miller in Ohio.
Speaker 2: George Santos in New York, and
you had David SHUSTER from Tennessee get reelected.
He introduced them?
Yeah.
Do you realize we have the largest Republican
Jewish caucus.
Speaker 1: For four years?
Very, very, very exciting, of course, for
the Republican Party.
So Santos should resign.
You'd be fired from any job for doing this.
And his argument that what he did wasn't a
crime is very, very shaky.
There's actually a longer interview that Santos
did.
It's a total softball.
I don't want to play the whole thing for you.
So we're going through it.
We're going to pull out the most interesting
clips and we'll look at them tomorrow.